[Music]
our team is the elite of the elite
we're the heart and soul of this very
Beach we protect when other people don't
want to protect and we go above and
beyond
[Music]
if you want me you can have me some
other target we're staring into the
abyss here
City Council's already cut our funding
it's up to us to restore the Baywatch
brand
I'm Matt Brody ready for duty you just
look at my boobs
I usually look at my face I'm trying but
it's so close to your boobs yeah this is
the guy you think it's a good PR
opportunity for us you some shots he's
reckless
with two gold medals I mean gold medals
do you have probably zero we got a dead
body on our Beach that's not our job
my gut says there's a bad [ __ ] going on
over there and my balls say we need to
check it out my balls say he's just
taking these rice
what are your balls sound like three
year old girls I don't know man that's
just how they talk but they're wise
welcome to Bay watch me so thankful why
does she always she's running his little
mouth you see it too
[Music]
you turned the canals into the dam
x-games yeah
that's cuz we were in lifeguard pursuits
there's no such thing as lifeguard
pursuit how do I explain this so that
you people understand you people you
people oh you don't get to say that
you're just ten right oh come on brother
[Music]
you